sie ist die erste autoren die
milliardärin geworden ist wenn ja es
gibt nicht viele autoren wie hambüchen
in serie heraus bringt die sich alle am
ersten tag 12 15 millionen mal verkaufen
ihre vorstellungskraft hat kinder und
erwachsene begeistert und jede branche
verändert die sie berührte harry potter
selbst war so groß wie ein kleiner
verlage
harry potter ist das maß aller dinge es
ist das größte film franchises aller
zeiten jk rowlings märchenhafte erfolg
wurde aus überlebenskampf und
herzschmerz geboren sie für arbeitslos
und alleinerziehend ich war die grösste
versagerin die ich kannte
mit einem ende wie aus dem bilderbuch
im mittelpunkt der finanziell
erfolgreichsten erzählung in der
geschichte der belletristik harry potter
steht die einzigartige und entschlossene
joanne rowling die so samt dem rektor
sie verkaufte um die 400 millionen
exemplare in den vereinigten staaten und
brachte eine milliarde kinder dazu
45 600 seitige welt so zu lesen und das
in einer zeit in der kinder überhaupt
keine bücher mehr larsen
mit wohl über zehn milliarden dollar an
gesamteinnahmen ist das ein absolut
erstaunliches franchise dass wir meiner
meinung nach nie wieder sehen werden die
popularität von harry potter hat rowling
in die ungewohnte welt der berühmtheit
katapultiert nachdem sie einst von
paparazzi gejagt wurde schränkt sie
heute den zugang zu ihrem privatleben
ein grund lehnte es ab an dieser
dokumentation mitzuwirken joanne rowling
wurde 1965 in plastischer england
geboren
schauspieler jim dale der von rowling
als sprecher für die harry potter
hörbücher in den vereinigten staaten
ausgewählt wurde kannte diese ländlichen
dörfern gut
in diesen kleinen städten lebten keine
reichen menschen alle gehörten zur
arbeiterklasse mann ging in die häuser
und sah die selbe tapete die man selbst
hatte denn es gab nur ein einziges
tapeten geschäft in der stadt es gab nur
einen genossenschafts laden und so sah
man das gleiche kleid das die eigene
mutter trug auch von zwei oder drei
anderen frauen getragen wurde das ist
also die art von umgebung rowlings
literarische ambitionen wurden schon
früh erkannt ihr erstes buch mit dem
titel haase stellte sie mit sechs jahren
fertig
nelly interviewte rowling für ihr buch
harry eine geschichte voller magie
es ging um ein kaninchen das krank wird
und bei all seinen anderen hasen und als
sie es fertig hatte brachte sie es
anscheinend ihrer mutter und sagte nun
veröffentliche es wird daraus jetzt etwa
kann ich nicht gemacht
auch hinter dem selbstvertrauen verbarg
sich unsicherheit wie rolling bei opa
gestammt ich bin kein mensch mit viel
selbstbewusstsein ich war niemand mit
besonders viel von irgendwas ich würde
sogar sagen ich war jemand mit wenig
selbstvertrauen und doch glaubte ich an
diese eine sache in meinem leben das war
die eine sache in meinem leben ich
fühlte dass ich eine geschichte erzählen
kann ihre geschichte wurde im task in
einem kleinen dorf in der grafschaft
gloucestershire geschrieben tanja cia
arbeitete als produzentin bei den ersten
vier harry potter filmen eng mit boeing
zusammen hatte sowohl einen
mikroskopischen als auch einen
mikrokosmos im blick auf hogwarts im
harry potter universum
sie war im westen des landes
aufgewachsen in der nähe des waldes von
dienen wo auch ich einen großteil meiner
kindheit verbracht hatte wir hatten also
eine menge gemeinsamer bezugspunkt
alles vorüber jay kay in ihren büchern
schreibt findet sich irgendwo in england
wieder das muss also wir haben die
fantastischen alten schlösser passen sie
haben diese wunderbaren alten gebäude
wir haben diese wälder die man anhand
ihrer beschreibung selbst kennt oder
dort in der nähe finden kann wo sie
einst gelebt hat
1980 wurde bei ihrer mutter multiple
sklerose diagnostiziert ein tragisches
ereignis für die familie doch das hielt
rowling nicht davon ab an ihrer
leidenschaft für die belletristik weiter
festzuhalten weder in der schule noch
später am college so hat in exeter
classic studiert da kommt alles her ihre
klassische bildung findet sich in den
harry potter büchern wieder die
griechischen mythen die christlichen
allegorien
nach dem college bezahlte rollin ihre
miete indem sie bei amnesty
international in london arbeitete wo sie
in ihrer mittagspause geschichten
schrieb
1990 hat sie dann in einem zug nach
london eine idee die ihr leben verändern
sollte
blieb stehen und ihr kam buchstäblich in
den kopf zauberer junge der nicht weiß
dass er ein zauberer ist geht auf eine
zauberer schule und weil sie keinen
stift hatte saß sie stundenlang da und
dachte nach während der zug weiter da
stand sie fing damit an der schule einen
namen zu geben sich gedanken über die
lehrer zu machen die mary potter und ich
erklärt sie was das für ein lebens
verändernder moment gewesen ist
dieses unglaubliche kribbeln das man
bekommt wenn man gerade jemanden
kennengelernt hat in dem man sich
vielleicht verlieben wird
die ganze harry welt war ihre
leidenschaft das ausmaß in dem dieser
enzyklopädische lebendige verstand
wusste was hinter einer tür sein würde
von der man noch nicht einmal wusste
dass es überhaupt gab war wirklich
erstaunlich
nur sechs monate später erhielt sie eine
herzzerreißende nachricht
ihre mutter war an multipler sklerose
verstorben rowling sprach mit der bbc
über ihren verlust
meister ich habe sechs monate vor ihrem
tod mit dem schreiben von harry begonnen
das ist das ist natürlich sehr
bedauerlich weil ich ihn nie gesagt habe
dass ich überhaupt schreiber sie hat
also nie etwas von harry potter erfahren
der tod von jobs mutter hat sich auf ihr
gesamtes schreiben ausgewirkt auf jede
einzelne seite von harry potter er hat
ihre ansichten von liebe und tod
verändert und davon was es bedeutet wenn
uns jemand verlässt und welche
auswirkungen das auf unser leben hat sie
konzentrierte sich zunehmend auf den
zauberjungen und wurde schließlich von
mehreren jobs gefeuert weil sie schrieb
anstatt zu arbeiten das war eine dunkle
zeit für die arbeitslose autorin rowling
beschloss england ganz zu verlassen
joanne rowling verließ england um in
porto portugal einen neuanfang zu machen
sie bekam einen job als lehrerin und
schrieb nebenher weiter
rowling heiratete einen lokalen
fernsehjournalisten und bekam innerhalb
eines jahres eine tochter aber nach
einer wie sie es nannte kurzen und
katastrophalen er zog sie nach edinburgh
schottland um in der nähe ihrer
schwester zu sein
ich glaube sie fühlte sich ein bisschen
als versagerin weil sie arm war weil sie
sehr gut ausgebildet war aber bisher
einfach keine karriere gemacht hatte ob
sie versuchte einen job als lehrerin zu
bekommen aber die arbeit war nicht
beständig und so musste sie öffentliche
hilfe in anspruch nehmen sie lebte von
der hand in den mund von tag zu tag in
absoluter armut am existenzminimum
es ist nicht glamourös und nicht
romantisch aber es hat dazu beigetragen
dass dieses buch letztendlich in
produktion ging
roman sagte dass der tiefpunkt die
grundlage für den wiederaufbau ihres
lebens war
in der wärme eines cafés weiter während
ihre tochter neben ihr schlief
und als sie die ersten drei kapitel hat
mit denen sie zufrieden war schickte sie
sie an einen agenten
es wurde abgelehnt
1995 schickte sie drei kapitel an die
agentur von chris liddell dort wurde es
genauso behandelt wie es für werke
unbekannter autoren üblich war wie
little in 60 minutes erzählte
diese dinge können ewig auf einen stapel
liegen man nennt ihn auch den matsch
laufen aber wie es der zufall wollte
nahm ich zwei tage später diesen stapel
in die hand und nahm ihn wird zum
mittagessen wenn meine begleitung spät
dran war und drinnen begann ich von
harry potter zu lesen und wir stellten
sich die nackenhaare auf aber zwölf
verleger lehnten das buch ab
niemand wollte weil es damals politisch
unkorrekt war internate zu bewerben es
war zwei mal so lang wie ein kinderbuch
sein durfte es hatte diesen ellenlangen
titel harry potter und der stein der
weisen es war genau das was verleger
damals nicht an büchern haben wollten
und so brachte er es nicht an den mann
das buch fand schließlich seinen weg zu
einem neuen kinderbuchverlag namens
bloomsbury
potter blieb ist medienanalyst und der
ehemalige verleger
die tochter des geschäftsführers hat die
ersten beiden kapitel gelesen ging sie
am theater und sagte sie wollen mehr
davon lesen es ist eben noch das schöne
am verlagswesen los geht zu einem großen
teil ums bauchgefühl
[Musik]
1996 sechs jahre nach dem rohling mit
dem schreiben von harry potter begonnen
hatte bloomsbury ja 4000 dollar für das
buch an das war nicht viel aber für
rowling war es magisch magic der moment
in dem er mir sagte dass bloomsbury das
buch übernehmen wollte war nach der
geburt meiner tochter der glücklichste
moment meines lebens
aber es gab einen haken um die
marktfähigkeit zu verbessern wollte
bloomsbury dass sie ihren namen in etwas
geschlechtsneutral es ändert wie little
in sexy - erklärte
traditionell lesen jungs nicht gerne
bücher die von mädchen geschrieben
wurden mädchen ist es egal wer die
bücher geschrieben hat aber jungs haben
diese seltsame sexistischer einstellung
john lee sich von ihrer großmutter
kathleen eine mittlere initiale und
wurde jay kay rowling
auf der buchmesse in bologna 1997 sprach
sich das buch schnell herum raffaele
wien vizepräsident von sco lästig war
dorthin geflogen um nach etwas
besonderem zu suchen
ich wollte bücher finden die nicht nur
im trend liegen oder gerade populär sind
sondern die von den kindern wirklich
geliebt und ihre lieblingsbücher werden
michael jacobs war zu diesem zeitpunkt
zehn jahre weiß präsident der
handelsabteilung von sco lästig es war
sicherlich ein buch das in bologna viel
aufsehen erregt hat und ich glaube für
alpha war als ziemlich offensichtlich
dass das buch das potenzial für eine
serie hatte aber das erste buch war
schon an und für sich außergewöhnlich
der in berlin bot eine beispiellose
summe von 105.000 dollar für die
amerikanischen rechte hand im ersten
harry potter buch
den anruf von christopher little erhielt
der ihr sagte dass ihr buch für 100 5000
dollar nach amerika verkauft wurde sagte
sie dass sie zum ersten mal sehr
erschrocken war es war einfach
überwältigend um ehrlich zu sein hatte
mich das leben in den letzten jahren so
sehr gebeutelt dass ich ziemlich
misstrauisch war wenn ich gute
nachrichten die guten nachrichten wurden
mehr 1997 wurde das buch in
großbritannien veröffentlicht und wurde
zum erfolg
die erste generation der schulhof potter
fans war geboren
rowlings zweites buch war bereits in
arbeit nachdem der erste harry potter zu
einem spitzenpreis als classic verkauft
worden war sie spürte einen enormen
druck den schwung beizubehalten der
verkauf nach amerika war in england eine
große sache eine unbekannte britische
autorin verkauft ihr erstes buch auf dem
amerikanischen markt der im gegensatz
zum englischen markt fünf oder sechsmal
so groß ist es war wie die geschichte
vom tellerwäscher
eine arme autorin wurde zum millionär in
die amerikanischen verleger hofften dass
harry potter abliefern würde
wir wussten dass wir etwas besonderes in
den händen hielten und das wussten wir
schon ziemlich früh unser ansatz war
also wirklich es wie einen blockbuster
zu veröffentlichen
[Applaus]
lässig eine art spezialeinsatzkommando
dass sich jede woche wegen harry potter
traf scola stick entschied sich für
einen interaktiven ansatz zur
vermarktung des buches the trading wir
haben das buch einigen auserwählten vor
veröffentlichung zum lesen gegeben ich
glaube einige von ihnen haben rowling
sogar treffen dürfen bevor das buch
überhaupt veröffentlicht wurde auf diese
weise haben wir also einen riesen wirbel
ausgelöst und als das buch dann in den
verkauf ging verbreitete es sich wie ein
lauffeuer
harry potter und der stein der weisen
verkaufte sich in zehn monaten über
800.000 mal und stand über ein jahr lang
auf der bestsellerliste der new york
times
als der zweite teil 1999 in den usa die
leben kam wurde die veröffentlichung der
potter bücher zu einem großen ereignis
skuletic zog die öffentlichkeit in
seinen bann
[Applaus]
sie veranstalteten zu jedem neuen titel
der heraus kam ein spektakel bei dem
buchstäblich tausende von kindern vor
den buchläden standen meist in kostümen
mitten in der nacht um ein exemplar
abzubekommen sexy logistik an einem tag
zehn oder elf millionen exemplare eines
buches auf den markt zu bringen war
schwierig wie sie sich sicher vorstellen
können die bücher zu transportieren
dafür zu sorgen dass sie sicher und
verschlossen waren sicherzustellen dass
die bücher niemandem in die hände fielen
bevor sie in jedermanns hände gelangten
die verkaufszahlen jedes einzelnen
buches stiege exponentiell an die erste
auflagen wurden viel viel größer
die einzige dunkle wolke die einen
schatten auf das wachsende phänomen warf
waren proteste konservativer religiöser
gruppen die in den mystischen
geschichten das böse sein sie
beschuldigten rowling hexerei und
okkultismus zu fördern und verbrannten
ihre bücher
[Musik]
auch wenn harry potter gerade die welt
im sturm erobert hat bis text keine
fiktion und keine fantasie hexerei ist
real der teufel ist real
die leute der meinung sind dass hexerei
in kinderbüchern per sie nichts zu
suchen hat dann ist die debatte wirklich
sinnlos denn viele klassische
kinderbücher würden aus den bibliotheks
regalen verschwinden wie der zauberer
von oz
selbst kardinal joseph ratzinger jetzt
papst benedikt der sechzehnte hatte
seine eigenen vorbehalte und die
amerikanische bibliotheks vereinigung
führte rowlings buch als den am meisten
angefochtenen text in den vereinigten
staaten an
dieser gegenwind hat allerdings keinen
einfluss auf die verkaufszahlen die
anhaltende vorherrschaft von harry
potter auf der bestsellerliste der new
york times zwang die zeitung schließlich
dazu eine eigene kategorie für
kinderbücher einzuführen ich bin mir
sicher dass unsere konkurrenten
glücklich darüber waren dass sie wieder
mehr plätze auf der bessere liste für
sich beanspruchen können und wir hätten
wahrscheinlich mit den ersten fünf
büchern die top-5 dominierte sogar die
hörbuch verkäufe brachen rekorde und
verzauberten die fans wie erzähler dem
del nach einer live lesungen new york
fest stellte
cargo vor handelt 400 kinder und mütter
waren da und ein kind schrie plötzlich
auf du hast einen satz ausgelassen als
ob es der größte fehler wäre und die
mutter sagte bitte entschuldigen sie ihn
aber er hat das ganze buch auswendig
gelernt und aus dem publikum hörte ich
andere kleine stimmen sagen ich auch ich
auch sauer frei
internationale vertriebe schnappten sich
die rechte zur übersetzung der bücher
und terry porter wurde zu einer
weltweiten sensation
[Musik]
die nachfrage wurde so groß dass für die
marke harry potter die gefahr bestand
außer kontrolle zu geraten
wir hatten supermärkte lebensmittelläden
tankstellen und andere einzelhändler die
plötzlich harry potter bücher haben
wollten um den umsatz anzukurbeln als
lockvogel angebot für ihr geschäft
rowling lehnte hunderte von lizenz
angeboten von sony microsoft und boeing
ab blieb aber ihrer vision treu wie sie
hier in sexy - erzählte sich die männer
die leute sehen könnten was für angebote
ich bekommen habe um harry in werbung
und jeder menge lächerlicher dinge
nutzen zu dürfen ich habe ausnahmslos
es gab ein angebot aus hollywood das sie
nicht ablehnen konnte und ein filmstudio
war dabei herauszufinden dass harry
potter wahre wunder bewirken könnte ich
arbeitete für eine neue produktionsfirma
von david hammond der zu mir sagte nun
ich las einen zeitungsartikel in dem
stand dass jemand das erste buch einer
siebenteiligen serie über einen kleinen
jungen geschrieben hatte der auf ein
internat geht und dann sechs dass er ein
sauberer ist als ich mich also mit ihrem
agenten traf und versuchte ihn davon zu
überzeugen uns das buch zu verkaufen
traten wir als warner brothers auf volle
garantien ist präsident des kino
resource von hollywood.com
[Musik]
ich glaube für warner brothers war seine
mission das harry potter franchise zu
bekommen ich meine warner brothers hatte
großen erfolg mit dem batman franchise
mit dem matrix franchise und ich glaube
sie waren fest entschlossen es zu
schaffen und ich glaube deshalb haben
sie den rohling so viel spielraum
gegeben was ihre kontrolle über diesen
prozess und über die filmreihe angeht
unser erstes treffen mit jockey rowling
fand beim mittagessen statt david hale
und ich hatte mir ein wenig darüber
erzählt was wir mit dem film machen
wollten und sie setzte sich mit uns
zusammen wir versuchten verzweifelt sie
zu beeindruckend sie brauchte uns
natürlich nicht zu beeindrucken denn das
hatte sie bereits getan
rowling hat angeblich zwei millionen
dollar von warner brothers für die
rechte an den ersten vier filmen
erhalten
es gibt nicht viele autorinnen und
autoren die immer wieder bücher einer
serie heraus bringen die sich alle am
ersten tag 10 12 15 millionen mal
verkaufen das cup ja eine menge einfluss
so konnte sie verlangen dass der film in
großbritannien mit einer rein britischen
besetzung gedreht wird und dass sie
sowohl bei der auswahl der schauspieler
als auch der regisseur ein wort
mitzureden hatte
top regisseure buhlten um zutritt
rowlings imaginäre welt nun ich weiß
dass man an steven spielberg herantrat
um beim ersten harry potter film regie
zu führen er wollte ihn eigentlich als
animationsfilm machen aber das kam nicht
zustande und so sprang chris columbus
ein produzent david heyman stellte die
handverlesene besetzung in einem ordner
brothers video vor
chris wahl von drei wunderbaren
britischen schauspielern für die
hauptrollen zeigt wie gut er den geist
dieser bücher versteht und ich glaube
ihr wichtigstes anliegen bei der
verfilmung ihrer vision wahr dass wir
den büchern treu bleiben ich glaube sie
hatte wirklich unglaublich hart daran
gearbeitet charaktere in einer
geschichte zu erschaffen an die sie
glaubte und sie wollte nicht dass das
zerhackt und falsch interpretiert wird
die größte herausforderung dabei die
acrolinx vision auf die leinwand zu
kriegen bestand darin dass zu dem
zeitpunkt als wir filmten bereits jeder
das buch gelesen hatte
hätten sie sich das jemals erträumen
können nicht in einer million jahren das
war das letzte was ich erwartet hatte
der erste harry-potter-film kam im
november 2001 in die kinos wieder einmal
bewirkte der zauber junge wunder der
film brach alle rekorde mit
90,3 millionen eingespielten dollar war
es das erfolgreichste
eröffnungswochenende des jahres der film
spielte anschließend 317 millionen
dollar ein und war damit der größte ein
spiel erfolg in den heimischen
kinokassen im jahr 2001 rowling behielt
nicht nur die kreative kontrolle sondern
handelte auch einen unbekannten
prozentsatz der film und lizenz gewinne
aus viel wichtiger ist aber dass sie mit
dem endprodukt zufrieden war
ich glaube als ich ihre reaktion auf die
fertigen filme sah habe ich gedacht wir
haben es geschafft es ist alles in
ordnung wir haben sie nicht im stich
gelassen
2001 war auch das jahr in dem joanne
rowling ihren 2 dr michael mary
heiratete
und die harry potter filme sind
weiterhin ein kassenschlager
jeder harry-potter-film stieg zum start
auf platz eins der kinocharts die
filmreihe hat einen perfekten
eröffnungswochenende rekord aufgestellt
die rede über ein jahrzehnt wir reden
über sieben filme
[Musik]
die ertragskraft ist vor das
einspielergebnis der sieben harry potter
filme ohne den zweiten teil von die
heiligtümer des todes liegt bei 6,4
milliarden dollar da sind heimvideos
fanartikel jegliche art von soundtracks
und alles andere noch nicht einmal mit
eingerechnet es ist das größte film
franchises aller zeiten
[Musik]
hält auch einen anteil an den verkäufen
der harry potter spielzeuge von mattel
und ihr fanartikel imperium expandiert
weiter
denn es ist schwer etwas zu finden das
nicht irgendwann einmal mit einem harry
potter bild versehen war es in der
gaming spielzeug oder sogar
bekleidungsbranche das ist ein enormer
erfolg
2010 bekam harry potter seinen eigenen
themenpark in den universe studios in
orlando der den namen the wizarding
world of harry potter trägt
und wieder einmal drückte rowling allem
ihren persönlichen stempel auf vom
schnee auf dem dach bis zum geschmack
des butterbier sie haben wirklich alle
zutaten eingetütet sind nach edinburgh
gefahren haben es hergestellt und dass
ihr präsentiert das da das ist
butterbier
sie hat zwei weitere kinder bekommen und
lebt jetzt auf einem pastoralen landgut
in nord schottland
und fünf jahre nach dem letzten potter
buch veröffentlichte rowling einen neuen
roman für erwachsene
ich bin von drachen und einhörnern und
all dem spaß der mit dem schreiben
dieser dinge verbunden ist zu einem buch
übergegangen das sehr persönlich ist und
viel von meiner realität ausdrückt
das buch mit dem titel ein plötzlicher
todesfall wirkte nicht den gleichen
zauber auf kritiker wurde aber trotzdem
zur nummer eins auf den bestsellerlisten
rowling hat erfolg in der literarischen
welt neu definiert
netto vermögen wird auf fast eine
milliarde dollar geschätzt womit sie zu
den reichsten frauen der welt gehört
[Musik]
die kammer muss sie hat sich zu einer
wunderbaren marke entwickelt was ihre
statur ihre ethik und ihr verhalten
angeht auf ihre großzügigkeit erstreckt
sich auch wohltätigkeitsorganisationen
zur unterstützung von kindern
alleinerziehender eltern armen menschen
und die multiple sklerose forschung
17 jahre lang hat rowling harry potter
gelebt und geordnet ihre geschichte war
ähnlich wie seine von der überwindung
schreckliche herausforderungen auf dem
weg zur außergewöhnlichem erfolg geprägt
wie sie 2008 der havard abschlussklasse
erzählte zu wissen dass man aus
rückschlägen weiter und stärker
hervorgegangen ist bedeutet dass man
sich seiner fähigkeit zu überleben immer
sicher sein kann man wird sich selbst
oder die stärke seiner beziehung aus
dann wirklich kennen wenn beides durch
widrigkeiten auf die probe gestellt
wurde ein solches wissen ist ein wahres
geschenk denn es war schmerzhaft herum
und es war mehr wert als jede
qualifikation die ich jemals erworben
habe
[Applaus]
[Musik]
er war nur eins dieser straßenkinder
jetzt ist er ein geschäftsführer mit
einem globalen 450 millionen dollar
ich glaube nicht dass jay sie jemals
neun musiker war er dachte er ich werde
dass jaycee unternehmen aufbauen
niemand hätte gedacht dass er so weit
kommen würde das eher clubs und mode
linien besitzen würde und alles andere
was er tut er hat damit geprahlt über
die grenzen der musik hinaus zu gehen
und das ist ihm gelungen
jay ist nicht zum mainstream
übergegangen er nahm den ganzen
mainstream und kaufte ihnen eine
eintrittskarte in seine welt
er entkam den dunklen weg den so viele
andere genommen hatten es passiert die
ganze zeit in diesem wohnprojekt du hast
ein bestimmtes leben und es führt
nirgendwo hin dass wird entweder ins
gefängnis oder es hört zum tod seine
überlebensfähigkeit und seit darstellung
führten ihn auf die reise seines lebens
er ging von der straßenecke zum eckbüro
als chef das war bahnbrechend
jersey ist ein brillianter texter ist
ein skrupelloser geschäftsmann und
jemand den jedes große unternehmen gerne
an der spitze haben würde
b sie hatte diese schrittweise aber sehr
tiefgreifende entwicklung vom stricher
zum chef und zu dieser phänomenalen hip
hop größe
anstatt nur irgendeiner zu sein hat er
sich zum ziel gesetzt der eine zu sein
und das ist einfach eine unglaubliche
leistung zu sagen ich bin nicht einer
sondern der eine
und das ist er der unbeholfene junge auf
den klassen porträt shawn corey carter
der zum megastar jaycee wird
sie wollte an unserem programm nicht
teilnehmen
shawn carter wurde am vierten dezember
69 in brooklyn new york geboren und war
das jüngste von vier kindern
er kam aus der hölle aus einem
kriegsgebiet das war dieser wohnkomplex
mercy projects in den 80ern die tatsache
dass er das überlebt hat so glaubwürdig
im spiel zu bleiben sie ist einzigartig
rapper kollege und früherer mentor jazz
lebte im selben
wir haben mit viel gewalt zu tun gehabt
wissen sie viel mord drogenhandel drogen
das war ein glück für einige von uns da
raus zu kommen aber viele die bekannten
haben es nie geschafft
seine musik handelte von seiner bewegten
vergangenheit aber er sprach selten
darüber sein offenes einstündiges
interview mit charlie rose im jahr 2007
war eine ausnahme die dinge die in
diesen vierteln an einem tag passiert
sind erleben andere in ihrem ganzen
leben nicht ich habe einen blick auf
dieses leben geworfen was mir hätte
passieren können wenn ich auf der straße
geblieben wäre
sie spielen russisches roulette mit
ihrem leben jeden tag 365 tage im jahr
irgendwann knackst du so ist das
es gab immer eine behinderung
irgendjemand
rosenblum laudenbach jaycees lehrerin in
der sechsten klasse
diese kinder sind mit schusswunden ins
bett gegangen wenn sie in ein
klassenzimmer kam dösten viele von ihnen
und ich ließ sie weil ich wusste dass
sie die halbe nacht wach waren
er war schüchtern und extrem aufgeweckt
er war überdurchschnittlich gut im lesen
er hatte diese angeborene fähigkeit
später lebte er darüber gute noten zu
bekommen aber dass er tief in seinem
inneren dämonen hatte die auf geweckt
wurden er lächelte welten und ich weiß
nicht ob es traurigkeit war oder einfach
nur seine persönlichkeit aber er war
immer irgendwie gelassen und lächelte
nicht als sei sie elf jahre alt war
verließ sein vater die familie in seinem
song dezember fonds sein geburtsdatum
schreibt er er sei ein zerrissenes kind
musikjournalisten secuemail greenberg
ich glaube dass er jaycee irgendwie kalt
gemacht und isoliert sehr verletzt und
ich glaube das hat ihn zu dem
berechnenden geschäftsmann gemacht der
er heute ist unsentimental
seine texte spiegeln distanz wieder
sei sie sagt in seinen eigenen songs er
habe seinem bruder in die schulter
geschossen weil er ein schmuckstück
gestohlen hat
das geld war knapp für seine
alleinerziehende berufstätige mutter und
es gab nur wenige jobs für einen
teenager
aber der drogenhandel brachte das
schnelle geld
dj mist dass sie ein führender new york
es ging darum schnell große summen
bargeld zu haben und niemandem
rechenschaft ablegen zu müssen
im grunde ging es darum geld zu
verdienen so gut wir konnten und als er
jung war war das halt crack verkaufen
auf der straße
barry michael cooper journalist und
filmemacher
es ist eigentlich seltsam der crack
verkauf hat ihm beigebracht unternehmer
zu sein die bedürfnisse und wünsche der
leute zu verstehen und eine nische in
dieser firma welt zu finden
seine liebe zur welt der platten so ganz
zu hause
seine mutter hatte diese plattensammlung
die in der gegend legendär war und jeder
kam immer um musik zu hören
sie ist ein genie er hat ein
enzyklopädisches wissen über alle
möglichen musikstile
es ist nicht nur hip hop marvin gaye
curtis mayfield barry james brown
natürlich aber auch rock'n roll die
stones
[Musik]
sie bekam keine musikalische ausbildung
hatte aber instinktiv das gefühl dass
rap sein weg aus diesem leben sein
könnte er schrieb texte auf servietten
auf papiertüten es strömte aus ihm
heraus
er hat gesagt dass er sieben oder acht
neue songs gleichzeitig im kopf
speichern kann das hat wirklich etwas
über die datenmenge aus die er
verarbeiten kann
sie war er ein sehr schneller rapper
und aber seine rap songs hatten auch
melodien das war einzigartig zu der zeit
ich habe vom ersten tag an ihn geglaubt
ehre 15 wir räumten und wir fingen an zu
vibrieren
ich hörte dass er pures talent hat es
ist einfach talent in seiner reinsten
form
cheseaux war als erster rapper bei ihrem
records unter vertrag
1988 nahm er in london das album work to
the jazz auf er nahm den 18-jährigen
jaycee mit und stellte ihm diesen songs
des albums hatte keinen erfolg und jay
sie kehrte nach hause zurück
ein kurzer ausflug in die
plattenindustrie bei einer enttäuschung
hatte ihm aber die augen für eine viel
größere wett
er war fokussiert genug um zu sagen
weißt du was ich kann das nicht ewig
machen mit drogen tieren denn das kann
nur auf zwei arten enden entweder du
stürzt oder du gehst ins gefängnis
ich hatte tolle leute um mich herum hat
sich an dieser weggabelung stand soll
ich entertainer werden oder auf der
straße bleiben ich habe mich entschieden
entertainer zu werden und es hat
geklappt ich habe den richtigen weg
eingeschlagen und habe es nie bereut
er machte sich in einer anderen art von
straßenschlacht einen namen
es gab rap kämpfer auf der straße die
nahkämpfe a cappella einfach aufeinander
losgehen und so hat sich durch die
straßenschlachten einen namen gemacht
und alle dachten wer ist dieser tür und
da fing es eigentlich an
er trat jahrelang auf partys und in
clubs auf bekam aber keinen
plattenvertrag frustriert schlug er
einen anderen weg ein
ich war von anfang an gezwungen
führungskraft zu sein denn ich musste
versuchen einen vertrag zu bekommen
bekam aber keinen ich ging zu jedem
einzelnen platten label und bekam keinen
deal also hieß es entweder aufgeben und
zurück auf die straße gehen oder mir
einen eigenen weg schaffen um gehört zu
werden
der gerade erst im künstlermanagement
angefangen hatte
das war damals so ein junger unternehmer
der vor allem werbung für partys machte
aber er managte auch einzelne auftritte
wenn man das setzte große hoffnung auf
den 24-jährigen jaycee sie gründeten ihr
eigenes label roc a fella records mit
einer dritten partnerin
sie drückten ihre eigenen cds machten
werbung packten aufkleber an club türen
sie fuhren durch die stadt und
verkauften die cds aus dem kofferraum
1995 wusste jeder in new york alles über
hiphop und wusste auch wer sie war
rockefeller hat es auf seine weise
gemacht sie finanzierten ihre videos
selbst auch viele ihrer touren weil sie
wussten je mehr geld sie ausgeben würden
sie auch für sich behalten
es waren ihre gewinne das war es was er
wollte sein geschäft das rockefeller wie
eine kapitalgesellschaft für
rockefeller veröffentlichtes debütalbum
reasonable doubt sie verkauften den drei
monaten über 500.000 cds
eine solide grundlage um weiter zu
wachsen
sie waren sehr gut in dem was sie taten
sie machten eine super promotion und die
musik von jaycee war so gut dass er das
wichtigste ist und dann ging es richtig
los und wurde zu dieser underground
sensation
in dem hitalbum reasonable doubt trat
auch ein klassenkamerad von jaycee
die beiden rapper aus brooklyn traten
oft zusammen auf bis zum neunten märz 97
in der nacht wurde notorious in los
angeles von einem unbekannten attentäter
erschossen
jaycee war erschüttert aber es war auch
der moment in dem er der prominenteste
rapper des landes wurde er war sehr
traurig weil er ihm sehr nahe gestanden
hat aber gleichzeitig wusste er dass es
eine erstklassige gelegenheit wahr diese
lücke zu füllen eine echte stimme von
der straße eine intelligente jaycees
wachsendes ansehen erregte die
aufmerksamkeit der musikindustrie größen
russell simmons und leo cohen und ihres
plattenlabels def jam
ich wollte rockefeller in der def jam
familie haben einfach weil ich diese
infrastruktur hatte
und ich brauchte wahnsinnig kreative
leute um diese infrastruktur zu nutzen
1997 kaufte def jam 50 prozent von
rockefeller records für 1,5 millionen
dollar
es war eine partnerschaft 50 50 es half
ihnen dabei das nächste level zu
erreichen und es gab ihnen eine
beteiligung
und genau darum geht es bei jesse und
beteiligung bei all seinen geschäften
bekommt er immer etwas an dem er
festhalten er ist wegen würde ich in
holland ihm
doch dann kam ein seltener fehltritt das
album in my life band ein
[Musik]
ich glaube das problem war in my life
war kein besonders gutes album jesse
klang plötzlich weicher um ein breiteres
publikum zu erreichen
des hardcore fans stellten seine
glaubwürdigkeit in frage
er sagte das album sei ihm entglitten er
brauchte eine wende und das schickte ihn
zurück in seine bewegte vergangenheit
hard knock life war ich meine das album
war sein thriller das war sein michael
jacksons thriller album
das war sein erster crossover hätte und
dass er nie thema in den kontext des
musikprojekts zu stellen ist ziemlich
brillant und es hat funktioniert das war
eine riesen erfolg
es schadet nicht dass er eine irrsinnige
arbeitsmoral hat er hat wirklich sehr
sehr hart daran gearbeitet dass zu
kreieren und zu promoten und es hat sich
gelohnt hat noch live brachte die sie
1999 einen grammy für das beste
rap-album 1 jaycee der superstar war
wieder da
es braucht so viel um voran zu kommen um
von einem unbekannten zu einer
berühmtheit zu werden
und ich denke er war bereit die firma
war bereit und die fans waren bereit
die fifty vor city tour für hard knock
life brachte 18 millionen dollar ein aus
album weitere fünf millionen
ende 99 gründeten jaycee und seine
partner das mode label rocawear mit dem
sie in 18 monaten 80 millionen dollar
umsatz
er versuchte wie andere zu sein
pickens oder donald trump sozusagen am
ende ging es ihm darum irgendwo in den
hamptons ein haus zu haben und einen
maybach zu fahren was er tatsächlich
auch tat wissen sie was ich meine
was auch immer der erfolg ihm gebracht
haben mochte frieden war es nicht sein
temperament kam plötzlich und heftig
wieder an die oberfläche es war etwas
das nicht hätte passieren dürfen und er
würde die als erster sagen das ist ein
schwerer fehler war mit 29 war jaycee
ein hip hop superstar und chef seines
eigenen multi millionen dollar
unternehmens er hatte jahre damit
verbracht sein image zu pflegen
bis er am ersten dezember 99 dem
produzenten lenz river im kit kat club
in new york mit einem messer
konnte lara gut und vertraute hat als er
von angeblichen raubkopien hörte rammte
er ihm eine 3 zoll klinge in den bauch
er hatte ihn gewarnt damit aufzuhören
und er tat es nicht dass alles in einem
raum voller zeugen er hatte alles zu
verlieren
sie wurde wegen körperverletzung zweiten
grades angeklagt er bekannte sich
schuldig und bekam drei jahre auch
bewähren
er hat fast alles durcheinander gebracht
aber er kam damit durch und sah aus als
wäre er der teflon rapper der teflon
rapper lernte dann seine diamanten diva
beyoncé knowles kennen
jahrelang vermieden sie erst über ihre
beziehung zu sprechen
es hat lange gedauert bis er diese
beziehung öffentlich bestätigt hat das
zeigt wie viel angst er da vorhatte zu
erkennen wie echt das war all dieses
teflon musste entfernt und das vertrauen
wieder aufgebaut werden sie ist die frau
die in dieser hinsicht das unmögliche
geschafft
während sich sein privatleben beruhigte
nahm sein geschäftsleben fahrer mit mehr
hits und auszeichnungen
ende 2001 erzielte seine modelinie über
100 millionen dollar umsatz
ein jahr später machte jaycee ein
schlagzeilenträchtige geschäft mit
reebok
es gab noch nie eine nicht sportler der
einen so großen stil mit einer der drei
top marken abgeschlossen hatte nike
adidas reebok sie verkauften innerhalb
einer stunde 10.000 paar
und dann bauten wir 100 millionen dollar
franchise mit dem namen escada auf
alles was er berührte schien feuer zu
fangen
auf beyoncés solokarriere als er in ihre
erfolgs single crazy in love auftrag
[Musik]
als ihr album durchstartete schockierte
er seine fans und verkündete seinen
rückzug aus der musik
weißt du ich bin zufrieden mit dem was
ich als solokünstler erreicht habe ich
frage mich was könnte ich noch erreichen
ich glaube er wollte einfach für eine
minute abstand nehmen er hat er das
gefühl alles getan zu haben was er tun
konnte
aber auf der anderen seite wollte er
vielleicht auch sehen wie die leute
darauf reagieren dass er in rente geht
der größte lebende
sein abschiedskonzert fade to black im
november 2003 im madison square gardens
war sofort ausverkauft jetzt sollte das
büro seine neue bühne werden
in tücher außen vor 2004 kaufte def jam
die restlichen anteile am rockefeller
für zehn millionen dollar
sie gaben bekannt dass jaycee präsident
und vorstand von sap jim werden würde
mit einem drei jahres vertrag im wert
von weiteren acht bis zehn millionen
dollar
[Musik]
wenn man sich seine vergangenheit
ansieht gibt es viele leute die ihm als
mentoren zur seite gestanden haben er
lernt er alles was sie ihm zu bieten
hatten und dann als er alles gelernt
hatte und er es nicht mehr brauchte ging
er weiter
[Musik]
bis ende 2004 hatte rocawear 300
millionen dollar eingespielt
keyboarder den er kaufte damon dash und
rockenberg loading für 30 millionen
dollar und verkaufte sie anderthalb
jahre später für 204 millionen an den
mode riesen iconix
typ ist ein genie und jedes mal wenn er
einen deal macht ist er wahrscheinlich
der klügste typ im rahmen
im hinterkopf denkt ja weißt du ich habe
geschäfte mit leuten gemacht die viel
furcht erregender sind als du er
beobachtet die leute was sie tragen was
sie tun wie sie zucken wie sich ihr
gesicht bewegt und dann wenn die zeit
reif ist kommt er mit seiner forderung
aber
er fand noch eine weitere rolle die des
philanthropen anstatt nur geld zu
verdienen begann er es zu verschenken
er gründete die shawn carter stipendien
stiftung für bedürftige studenten
2006 traf er sich mit kofi annan bei der
uno um auf eine umweltkrise aufmerksam
zu machen die globale wasserknappheit
alle 15 sekunden steht dein kind ich
freue mich sehr rauszugehen nicht nur
ein rockstar zu sein sondern auch zu
helfen es hat ihn zu einem globalen
botschafter gemacht seiner
persönlichkeit eine neue dimension
gegeben man kann ihn nicht mehr einfach
nur als rapper bezeichnen
als chef von def jam records baute sie
die karrieren von künstlern wie rihanna
& young jeezy aus und war aber auch
bereit für einen weiteren eigenen hätte
drei jahre nach seinem rückzug
veröffentlichte er kindern kam das album
verkaufte sich in der ersten woche über
680.000 macht
2007 endete sein vertrag bei dem er nahm
die rechte an seinen aufnahmen mit eine
potenzielle goldmine
ehemaliger musikredakteur beim time
magazine und jetzt redakteur der
bloomberg
ich denke dass einzigartiger und jesse
als geschäftsmann ist dass er genau weiß
wo er sein will und nicht entgleist er
ist opportunistisch war aber von anfang
an auch sehr strategisch
er glaubt dass ein geschäft nicht
erfolgreich ist wenn die andere seite
nicht auch gewinnt er ist ein winner typ
vielleicht neigt er dazu selbst etwas
mehr zu gewinnen seine langfristige
strategie umfasste eine reihe lukrative
werbeverträge mit dem konzern giganten
budweiser heineken und co
er weiß sehr genau was er zu tun bereit
ist und was nicht er würde sein image
seinen namen und den guten willen nie
für geld für drehen oder opfern
jeder wollte mit ihm geschäfte machen
im april 2008 unterschrieb er beim
konzert giganten live nation einen
zehnjahresvertrag der touren
veröffentlichung und aufnahmen fast
als die einnahmen der plattenindustrie
rückläufig waren kam live nation mit
einem sogenannten 360
was bedeutet dass sie ein stück von
allen bekommen was er tut für sie war
das brillant denn während der kuchen in
der musikindustrie immer kleiner wurde
bot dieses unternehmen einen viel
größeren kuchen und garantierte
einnahmen sie nahmen einen teil des
risikos und die belohnung über viel
größer in derselben woche besiegelte er
einen weiteren deal die presse stellte
fest dass er und beyoncé verheiratet
waren
wenn jaycee und beyoncé heiraten ist das
als würden bmw und mercedes zusammen
gehen das war die stärkste promi marke
der welt
und dann die neue new yorker national
100 sie natra von seinem thron stieß
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das album the blueprint schrieb
musikgeschichte es war das elfte nummer
eins eine mehr als elvis presley der
king wurde von einem hip hopper überholt
[Musik]
dass jaycee elvis überholt hat ist
einfach bemerkenswert
es führt ihn wirklich aus dem reich des
hiphop und bringt ihn in die oberen
ränge oder den höchsten rang der
popkultur er ist jetzt 40 jahre alt er
könnte mit 50 milliardär sein
sie wollte sich im geschäft profilieren
und er wollte dass das noch lange
nachwirkt sein ehrgeiz ist phänomenal
und hat eine wilde geschwindigkeit
er ist schnell er ist wütend er wollte
schon lange ein zeichen setzen das hat
diesen kerl am laufen gehalten
dass jemand der im grunde eine outlook
persönlichkeit war zum massen
unterhalter und geschäftsmann wurde ist
einfach eine enorme leistung
man hat ihn das orakel von omaha genannt
den weißen von der baske und schon in
jungen jahren wusste er das erreicht
werden würde als ich zehn jahre alt war
war mir klar dass mich ein langes leben
habe am ende viel geld haben würde und
hinter seinem volkstümlichen auftreten
verbirgt sich einer der gewieftesten und
härtesten geschäftsmänner amerika jonas
keine 40 milliarden dollar in dem an
mister rogers oder einer der muppets ist
warum geht über leichen wenn es um eine
verhandlung geht er nutzt jeden hebel
den er hat
warren buffett hat die risikoreichen
spekulationen
er lebt und arbeitet in omaha wo er 1930
geboren wurde und wo seine besessenheit
von allen finanziellen dingen begann ich
wusste dass ich mich für den rest seines
lebens für aktien interessieren würde
schon als ich acht oder neun war ich
führte tabellen über alle möglichen
aktien
eine tante schenkte mir einen weltall
nach und so lernte ich die
bevölkerungszahlen aller größeren städte
auswendig ich mochte einfach zahlen
nicht nur wirtschaftszahlen
kafitz fähigkeit sich an diese zahlen zu
merken sollte die grundlage für seinen
späteren erfolg sein
großvater hat einen lebensmittelladen
ich kaufte bei ihm coca cola im
sechserpack für ein quarter und
verkaufte sie für einen fünfer bestellt
er verkaufte zeitungen an türen ich
hatte alle möglichen kleinen projekte
nicht alle sehr erfolgreich aber ich
machte von klein auf kerngeschäfte mit
16 schrieb sich buffett an der wharton
school der universität von pennsylvania
ein wo er mit charles peterson zusammen
bunte jeden tag nach dem unterricht
verbrachte ich so viele stunden damit
krieg zu studieren ich nahm die bücher
in die hand und saß da und blätterte
seite für seite
und er konnte in ein paar wochen zwei
oder drei kurse durcharbeiten
er hatte ein fotografisches gedächtnis
ich nicht
buffett entdeckte auch früh seine liebe
zur politik ich war präsident des klubs
der jungen republikaner an der uni von
pennsylvania und kandidierte sogar
einmal als delegierter für den
landeskongress als republikaner
nachdem er das college beendet hatte
machte paffett einen abschluss an der
columbia business school und kehrte nach
omaha zurück um sein eigenes unternehmen
zu gründen er sagte ich werde eine
gesellschaft gründen und er fragte
willst du mitmachen ich sagte natürlich
will ich zunächst waren wir nur sieben
oder acht leute und noch weitere
investoren zu überzeugen wurde schon
schwieriger eine verkaufs gespräche
waren nicht sehr effektiv ich war 20
jahre alt so ausgeht 16 und benahm nicht
wahrscheinlich wie ein 12-jähriger ich
ging herum und sprach die leute an die
waren immer nett zu mir aber ich ging zu
irgendeinem an und erklärte ihm all
diese fakten und zahlen warum man aktien
kaufen sollte wenn ich dann mit allem
durch war zählte ich bis 31 23 und dann
sagte der mann was sagt ihr vater ich
hätte ihn hauen können
es war frustrierend buffett wusste dass
er ein besserer verkäufer werden musste
also wandte er sich an den bekannten
selbsthilfe guru dale carnegie ich
musste besser mit menschen kommunizieren
vor allem in gruppen ich wusste einfach
dass sich diese angst vor öffentlichen
auftritten loswerden musste und ich
hatte von diesem dale carnegie kurs
gehört ich habe meiner frau während
dieses kurses einen heiratsantrag
gemacht also ich bin direkt auf meine
kosten gekommen jetzt konnte war wird
endlich seine karriere in gang bringen
er wählte aktien aus die andere
ignorierten und seine papiere stiegen
immer weiter
nach und nach sprach sich in omaha herum
dass der junge mann wusste was er tat
in den ersten fünf jahren in denen
buffett im geschäft war stieg der dow um
74 prozent während basels anlagen um 250
prozent zulegen
1961 im alter von 30 jahren wurde er
millionär
aber das sah man seiner familie nicht an
ihr haus in dem buffett immer noch lebt
sie kaufte er vor über 50 jahren für
32.000 dollar seine kinder gingen alle
auf öffentliche schulen
susi buffett ist das älteste von drei
kindern
wir sind auf eine art aufgewachsen die
wahrscheinlich anders ist als die der
meisten kinder die einen vater haben der
das hat was mein vater hat sie haben
keine autos bekommen als wir 16 waren
wir haben nicht wirklich anders gelebt
als die meisten anderen kinder die wir
kannten
die größte veränderung im buffett
haushalt bestand darin dass warren sich
vom republikanismus seines vaters ab
wann
die bürgerrechte hatten den größten
einfluss auf meine einstellung zur
politik keine der beiden parteien hat
sich unbedingt mit ruhm bekleckert die
demokraten schienen sich darauf viel
mehr einzustellen als die republikaner
mit anfang dreißig wollte warren buffett
unternehmen finden an denen er eine
mehrheitsbeteiligung erwerben konnte und
er fand eines 100 meilen entfernt in
beatrice nebraska remstal war ein
unternehmen wirklich nicht gut gehen es
war ein windmühlen geschäft tätig
windmühlen sind ja heute wieder ankommen
aber vor 50 jahren war das kein gutes
geschäft die aktien wurden sehr billig
gehandelt also kauf mich welche die
ehemalige wall street analystin eloise
roda ist die autorin von der schneeball
brothers autorisierter lebensgeschichte
es war ein unternehmen das große
lagerbestände aufgebaut hatte dies nicht
brauchte und die belegschaft war viel zu
groß das unternehmen musste einfach
verkleinert werden die staaten der es
war sehr klein und es war der
hauptarbeitgeber
warum dort menschen verloren ihren job
buffett musste dafür geradestehen was
warren buffett daraus gelernt hat ist
dass er sich nicht mehr in unternehmen
einmischen wollte die arbeits probleme
hatten in denen er leute entlassen
musste in denen er sich persönlich in
das management einmischen musste er
wollte dass jemand anderes das tut auch
was sitzt nächste große investition sah
nach einem möglichen misserfolg aus
deren aktien für 7 dollar rund 50 wir
haben einen text ihr unternehmen gekauft
das wie jedes andere textilunternehmen
in uk dazu bestimmt war irgendwann zu
verschwinden das war ein fehler glänzen
ist geschäftsführender gesellschafter
von tieto partner
war kein gutes unternehmen sie hatten
keinen wettbewerbsvorteil der es ihnen
ermöglicht eine ausreichende rendite zu
erwirtschaften sie waren zwar in
gewissem maße profitabel aber diese
rentabilität wurde unaufhaltsam kleiner
als das geld aus berkshire hathaway
herausgezogen wurde wurde es
reinvestiert die erste große
reinvestition die sehr profitabel war
war das versicherungsgeschäft und das
trieb alles an was berkshire hathaway
von da an tat
verlagerte das unternehmen also von der
textil zur versicherungsbranche zum teil
deswegen weil die branche selbst gewinne
ab war aber auch weil buffett die
prämien die er von seinen
versicherungsnehmern bekam wieder in
aktien investieren konnte
man float die versicherungsprämien
bringen zinslos geld einbringen das dann
in andere unternehmen investiert werden
da wird fand auch einen partner der
genauso markt konnte ich war wie er
charlie manga der als anwalt arbeitete
als die beiden sich kennenlernten
als ich war in kennenlernte erzählte er
mir wie viel besser seine lebensweise
sei und dass sich zu klug sei um in
einem so dünnen geschäft wieder
anwaltspraxis zu arbeiten während ich
wie er eine investitions partnerschaft
leiten könnte
und ich brauchte etwa zwei oder drei
jahre um zu erkennen er hatte recht
in den späten 60er jahren erlebte die
wall street einen beispiellosen boom die
kurse schossen hoch und jeder stürzte
sich in den aktienmarkt aber für buffett
war es an der zeit auszusteigen
ich hatte etwas mehr als 100 millionen
dollar und viele glückliche partner
und die schrieben einen brief ich sagte
ich weiß nicht mehr wie ich dieses spiel
spielen soll die bewertungen sind so
gestiegen dass ich nicht mehr finden
kann ich beendete man eine partnerschaft
es scheint nicht intuitiv zu sein aber
rollen hat immer gas louis zitiert der
sagte sei gierig wenn andere ängstlich
sind so ängstlich wenn andere gierig
sind und waren wusste dass die party
irgendwann zu ende ist und die blase
platzen wird
auf etwa 40 jahre alt und über 25
millionen dollar schwer
aber er war unruhig und traf 1973 die
schicksalhafte entscheidung sich in eine
kalifornische bank namens risko
einzukaufen
das problem war jesko befand sich mitten
in einem fusions geschäft mit einem
anderen unternehmen und der handel
schwerter sich das unternehmen das risko
kaufen wollte bei der
börsenaufsichtsbehörde würde versuchen
ihre fusion zu verhindern was illegal
gewesen wäre daraufhin wurde eine
untersuchung eingeleitet
die börsenaufsicht untersuchte jeden
winkel von buffetts geschäft ins
business ist und was sie sah alarmierte
sie öffnet und mangas investitionen
waren ein komplexes spinnennetz von
eigentum und kreuz beteiligungen wir
waren da hineingeraten weil wir mehrere
unternehmen hatten das ganze sah aus wie
eine menge spaghetti das für irgendeinen
bösen zweck gemacht worden war
wir haben nicht das gefühl dass wir
etwas verbotenes getan hatten aber es
gab viele regeln und die frage ob wir
gegen welche verstoßen hatten
stanley brocken war vollstreckung
direktor bei der börsenaufsicht
immer wenn man feststellt dass dinge so
verdrahtet sind dass es lange dauert bis
man sie versteht der nun kommt der
verdacht auf dass jemand das vielleicht
tut um mit etwas davon zu kommen
was die ermittler ebenfalls stutzig
machte war die tatsache dass manga und
buffett den aktionären an der westküste
einen höheren preis für ihre aktien
anbieten als sie auf dem freien markt
erzielen konnten also kauften wir
einfach weiter bis unser kontingent
erschöpft war und zwar um 2 oder 3
punkte höher als wir mussten das war
zwar sehr eigenwillig aber wir hielten
es für das richtige und die
börsenaufsicht drehte durch
um eine katastrophe abzuwenden wandte
sich buffetts anwalt mit einem
unorthodoxen ab
er sagte sie malz denn auch wenn das in
deinen augen nicht gut aussieht möchte
ich dass du dir den charakter dieser
person an guckst in meiner meinung nach
wird er wahrscheinlich die nummer eins
der finanzdienstleistungsbranche aller
zeiten
wir ab helen hatte erfolg das
unternehmen wurde zu 100.000 dollar
strafe verurteilt aber es wurde keine
anklage gegen buffett erhoben
[Musik]
stieg auf 93 dollar
wobei die gewinne vor allem auf das
versicherungsgeschäft
zurückzuführen waren buffett hatte auch
anteile an banken kleider herstellern
und süßwarenfabrik aber bei einem
unternehmen war er besonders
leidenschaftlich ich liebe zeitung
gemerkt ich habe angefangen zu lesen
wissen sie mein vater brachte sie mit
nach hause ich weiß nicht ob ich sechs
oder sieben oder acht war aber es war
das erste was ich mir schnappte und
schwestern auch
sein erster zeitungs kaufe ein omaha
wochenblatt namens besser die zeitung
gewann einen pulitzer-preis eine seltene
auszeichnung für ein kleines blatt
dann begann er aktien der washington
post company zu kaufen die zeitung war
nach dem watergate skandal finanziell
angeschlagen
[Musik]
1973 waren die aktien stark gefallen
auch weil die nächsten regierungen der
washington post sozusagen den krieg
erklärt hatte
[Applaus]
das interessante ist als wir diesen
staaten für 20 dollar die aktien kauften
wenn man die leute die sie uns
verkauften gefragt hätte wie viel das
unternehmen eigentlich wert ist hätten
sie gesagt 100 dollar pro aktie und sie
haben trotzdem verkauft der ich bin der
nächsten regierung auf ewig dankbar dass
sie damals den staub aufgewirbelt
buffett hatte sich immer von den
führungskräften seines unternehmens
herrn behalten
aber das war bei der washington post und
der fall wo die verlegerin graham seine
gesellschafts partnerin und vertraute
wurde
sie bei einer branche tätig die mich
fasziniert und zwei zu verschiedenen
partys in washington ein die sehr
interessant war ich sah teile der welt
die ich sonst nicht gesehen hätte
geworden werden
aber während sich basis
gesellschaftlicher kreis erweitert
fühlte sich seine frau susie zu hause
zunehmend isoliert und traf eine
entscheidung chili sich nicht von rohr
entscheiden wo sondern ging nach san
francisco und cisco um ein neues leben
zu beginnen
ich verstehe warum sie umgezogen ist
mein vater wurde immer berühmter und
meine mutter war so gar nicht der misses
wollen buffett typ ihre beziehung hat
sich nie verändert sie waren total
verliebt haben fünf sechs sieben acht
mal am tag miteinander gesprochen sind
zusammen verreist sie konnte bloß
einfach nicht hier leben
um sicherzustellen dass waren in ihrer
abwesenheit versorgt war wandte sich
susi an ihre freundin astrid mengs nach
ein paar monaten zog passt wird es ist
eher unorthodox eine menge leute haben
sicher darüber geredet und alle
möglichen netten sachen darüber gesagt
wie seltsam das sei aber ich denke mir
weißt du was es geht niemanden was an
was in der beziehung anderer passiert es
hat für die drei funktioniert
funktioniert
dorfes ging in die geschichte ein als er
bei der übernahme der american
broadcasting company durch capital city
half dem bis dahin größten medien aber
sein goldenes händchen reichte nicht aus
als buffett 700 millionen dollar in
soliman brothers investiert dem damals
größten investment einige jahre später
geriet solle man in große schwierigkeit
sonnengarten bottrop es wurde brenzlig
als ich im august 91 einen anruf bekam
bedeutete mir an welche probleme auf
mich zukam ein händler namens moschee
hat er einige sehr schlimme dinge auf
dem us staatsanleihenmarkt getan zu
diesem schlimmen dingen gehörten
illegale hand dieses soll und händler
der den anleihemarkt durch den einsatz
nicht genehmigte konnten in die enge
trieb um den anteil von solle man zu
erhöhen und die konkurrenten zu
verbringen
war stellvertretender vorsitzender solle
man nun er war entsetzt über das was
geschah
mir war klar dass wir gegen das gesetz
verstoßen haben wir hatten uns in die
funktion eines wichtigen marktes
eingemischt und die zentralbank wäre
nicht begeistert
[Musik]
ich erinnere mich lebhaft daran wenn man
es auf die titelseite der new york
anschafft kam mit bild aber ein dummkopf
da wurde meine notlage landesweit
bekannt das war wahrscheinlich einer der
schlimmsten tage meines lebens
[Musik]
an der wall street wird gemunkelt dass
die spitze von solomon ihren rücktritt
angeboten hat um einen ausschluss des
unternehmens als haupt händler für
staatsanleihen zu verhindern
good friend unternahm einen letzten
verzweifelten versuch das unternehmen zu
retten indem er in omaha anrief und
buffett bat den chef posten zu
übernehmen
ich hab mich da raus um eine reine weste
zu machen wir hofften dass ich das
vertrauen der leute gewinnen würde die
bieten auf und
davon gab es jede menge
die krise verschärfte sich als
finanzminister nicholas brady anordnete
das solle man aus dem anleihegeschäft
aussteigt
es wurde an einem sonntagmorgen bekannt
gegeben dass das us-finanzministerium
uns von der liste der wirklich
akzeptablen leute der primärhändler
gestrichen hatte das wäre der todesstoß
gewesen also musste ich was tun und zwar
bis zum handelsstart in tokio
das war eine nationale katastrophe
gewesen und es sah lange zeit so aus als
würde die regierung einfach sagen zum
teufel mit der sohle monrose sommer
buffett verbrachte den ganzen tag mit
verzweifelten telefonaten nach
washington um die regierung zum rückzug
zu beginnen ich war zu tode erschrocken
und das würde man ihn eher
wahrscheinlich auch an viele leute
wollten dass wir an diesem wochenende
das geschäft aufgeben er hatte ich
wusste nicht was passieren würde gegen
23 uhr gab minister brady soll immer
noch eine chance und das geschäft zu
besiegeln borste buffett persönlich
ich war neun monate und vier tage dort
und das ist kein zufall dass nicht 20
jahre später genau sagen kann wie lange
ich dort war aber es war wichtig das zu
erledigen ich würde niemandem wünschen
was mit der firma passiert ist aber
neben gewisser weise habe ich viel
gelernt und
buffett trifft sich mit der
finanzgemeinde gibt autogramme sie
lieben ihn der mann mit dem blitz
sauberen image der versuch das chaos bei
soul on brothers zu beseitigen
1993 erreichte der aktienkurs
17.000 dollar
aber keine noch so große weltreise
konnte bei fisch wohnheim ändern herbeth
lasst uns über wollens ernährung
sprechen hier ist das gemuese dass er
ist
mais am kolben pommes kartoffelpuffer
und das obst wäre bananen creme torte
erdbeerkuchen
ich glaube das war schon an obst bringt
auch mehrere kirsch cola am tag ich habe
den mann noch nie in meinem leben und
das ist kein witz einen schluck wasser
trinkt gesehen niemals
die 90er und 2000er jahre waren die zeit
der größten expansion
das unternehmen holte sich das größte
möbelhaus des landes future store einen
führenden hersteller von wohnmobilen
benjamin moore pains dairy queen geico
insurance insgesamt über 70 unternehmen
mit 250.000 beschäftigten
einige investitionen erschienen
unkonventionellen roux ist er kaufte die
zeitung seiner heimatstadt den omaha
world
und die eisenbahngesellschaft burlington
northern rock das ist es was warren
buffett immer wieder gemacht hat wenn er
in etwas investiert dann schaut jeder
drauf und sagt ich habe es doch gesehen
warum habe ich das nicht gleich erkannt
in omaha wurde die
jahreshauptversammlung von berkshire
hathaway zu einer pilgerstätte für
zehntausende von aktionären es ist
wirklich erstaunlich das stadion ist
voll und die scheinwerfer sind auf einen
kleinen klapptisch gerichtet an dem zwei
80-jährige sitzen und diese beiden 80
jährigen haben mehr ausdauer als alle
anderen im raum
und freitag bis sonntagabend ist ein
nonstop unterwegs und je länger das
wochenende dauert desto mehr energie hat
er
ich kann es nicht erklären es muss an
den prager anliegen
in den 2000er jahren war waffe zu sich
milliarden dollar
geld das er an eine stiftung geben
wollte wie seine frau susie bleiben
sollte sie
doch 2004 statt sowie an einem
schlaganfall nach einer krebsoperation
es war ein großer schock für uns alle
mein vater ich kann ich erklären wie
sehr er sie geliebt hat und wie sehr er
sich auf sie verlassen hat ich fange an
zu weinen wenn ich darüber rede
wissen sie er wird nie ganz darüber
hinwegkommen keiner von uns wird das
wahrscheinlich sie war wirklich etwas
ganz besonderes war schon
zwei jahre nach dem tod seiner frau
heiratete buffett menge bei einer
privaten feier
und gab bekannt dass er den großteil
seines vermögens nicht seinen kindern
juden sondern der stiftung von bill und
melinda gates verriet bill gates ist
seit den frühen 90er jahren einer von
buffetts engsten freund
los es war phänomenal
konnten viel ehrgeiziger an viele dinge
herangehen die wir sonst nicht hätten
tun kann es ist jedes jahr ein
gigantisches geschenk mit dem wer
doppelt so erfolgreich sein können wie
wir es ohne je gewesen wären
[Musik]
buffett für eine berühmte persönlichkeit
und ein brillianter geschäftsmann
als die us amerikanische wirtschaft 2008
in die krise geriet war buffett erneut
der retter vieler finanzinstitute die
unter den schuldenbergen zusammenbrachen
der dow schloss am montag mit einem
minus von mehr als 500 punkten
warren buffett ist ein riesiges
gütesiegel für gute haushaltsführung
nation wenn er geld in eine sache steckt
kann man davon ausgehen dass er klug
genug ist diese investition zu tätigen
weil er glaubt dass er damit eine gute
rendite erzielen wird und das beruhigt
die leute wenn die angst am größten ist
zu den unternehmen die von warren
buffett unterstützt wurden gehört
aber inzwischen ist buffett über 80 und
es bleibt die frage wer wird der
nachfolger dieser finanziert ohne an der
spitze von
es wurde bereits jemand gefunden aber
sein name noch nicht veröffentlicht been
made public
was buffett jedoch verrät sind die
politischen und wirtschaftlichen anlegen
die ihm am herzen
ich glaube in den letzten jahren hat er
einige sachen gesehen wo er dachte da
nicht den mund aufmache könnte das etwas
bewirken
was er am lautesten anspricht sind die
ungerechtigkeiten des steuersystems tech
system es war es das als affe triegel
bekannt wurde es gibt alle möglichen
superreichen die normale steuern zahlen
aber es gibt eine kleine gruppe die man
sehr leicht finden kann die sehr
niedrige steuern zahlt mich
eingeschlossen
er schätzt sich glücklich zu diesem
zeitpunkt der geschichte in amerika
geboren worden zu sein
ich glaube er ist einer der
eindrucksvollsten
friedlichsten menschen die ich je
getroffen habe er hat mit dem was er
getan hat viel bewegt und jeder mit dem
er zu tun hatte hat damit geld verdient
und sein leben verbessert
es gibt wirklich niemanden wie bohren
wir sollten uns zurücklehnen und von den
tiefgründigen überlegungen profitieren
die er seit seiner jugend über die
wirtschaft angestellt hat
ich habe einfach jeden tag eine tolle
zahl ich warne ich fang an genau das zu
tun was ich im leben tun wird besser
geht's nicht
er ist rücksichtslos
ein medienmagnat der ein globales
imperium im wert von mehr als 80
milliarden dollar schuf er liebt das
mediengeschäft er ist 24 stunden am tag
7 tage die woche damit beschäftigt er
isst schläft und trinkt es sie das volk
in den medien kommt nicht so leicht und
schnell rupert murdoch von news corp ist
ein moderner presse warum herrscher über
zeitungen und zeitschriften
fernsehsender und kabelkanäle
filmstudios und satellitensysteme die
oft die botschaft ihres provokanten und
polarisierenden chefs die das spiegelt
seine redakteure wissen was rupert will
und setzen das auch gerne um seit mehr
als 50 jahren baut murdoch sein reich
stück für stück auf und
löst dabei feuer stürme der kontroversen
aus rupert murdoch ist die verkörperung
des bösen
ist nicht mehr die angesehene zeitung
die sie einmal war uns entfacht bittere
rivalitäten es ist ein zeitungs krieg es
gibt immer jemanden der sterben muss
damit du leben kannst und rupert ist gut
weil er mehr schmerz ertragen kann als
jeder andere
diese kämpfe führten sein unternehmen
von den höhen des erfolgs an den rande
des zusammenbruchs und wieder zurück
hubert geht es vor allem um macht man
könnte was sagen er ist größenwahnsinnig
er will so viel besitzen so viel
einfluss haben wie er kann er will der
größte und beste sein den es je gab oder
geben wird
madoff wurde schon als vieles bezeichnet
sogar in seinem eigenen netzwerk ich bin
rupert murdoch der tyrannische
milliardär und das ist meine skybox wenn
du rupert murdoch ist beweise es
[Musik]
murdoch präsenz im film fernsehen und
printmedien ist in fast allen teilen der
welt zu spüren
rupert murdoch ist das was gott meinte
als er einen medienmanager schuf er hat
alle eigenschaften die ein medienmanager
braucht er hat visionen er hat mut wer
geht risiken ein und er geht an die
grenzen
seiner serien startete mit einer kleinen
zeitung in australien und wurde zu einem
der größten medienunternehmen der welt
mit über 150 zeitungen internationalen
fernsehsendern und einem filmstudio ende
movie studio die news corporation hat
einen jährlichen umsatz von etwa 32
milliarden dollar der mann der so viel
von dem kontrolliert was wir sehen
wollte nicht von uns interviewt werden
wie es auch nur 1 4
obwohl er seine politischen ansichten
nie versteckt hat ich würde sagen
unterstützt die bush politik im nahen
osten auch wenn wir sein vorgehen sehr
kritisch gesehen haben oder seine
ambitionen extrem rücksichtslose wusste
was er wollte und nichts würde ihn davon
abhalten das zu bekommen ich glaube das
war wahrscheinlich
sein markenzeichen der anfang und der
kern seines imperiums die zeitung
[Musik]
im zeitungsgeschäft aufgewachsen er hat
ein erfolg gefunden er liebt das
tagesgeschäft ich habe ihn eine zeitung
lesen das ist ein körperlicher art es
ist so körperlich mit einer frau liebe
zu machen
diese besessenheit lag in seinen genen
rupert murdoch wurde am 11 märz 1931 als
sohn des prominenten zeitungsmann circus
murdoch und seiner frau lady elisabeth
murdoch geboren er wuchs auf der
familienfeier außerhalb von melbourne
australien auf und besuchte
ich weiß nicht ob es mir gefallen hat
oder nicht ich habe damals nicht darüber
nachgedacht aber die meisten sind
sicherlich glücklich aber er fühlte sich
fehl am platz und leben von den kindern
der melbourner elite andrew butscher
vizepräsident für
unternehmensangelegenheiten und
kommunikation bei news corp
kam auf einen privilegierten umfeld aber
sein vater besaß das unternehmen nicht
in dem er arbeitete er leitete es sah
sich selbst immer als außenseiter er
biete darin auf es gab ihm einen
wettbewerbsvorteil
er hob sich noch weiter ab als er nach
oxford ging für seine vorliebe für die
kommunistische philosophie meinen
spitznamen einbrachte der rote ruppert
das war wohl das produkt seines
rebellischen geist ich bin sicher dass
er gegen seine eltern rebellierte wo er
konnte und gegen die werte seiner eltern
sowie die meisten jungen leute mango mit
canon war ein junger journalist in
australien der später mit murdoch
zusammenarbeitet ich glaube dass rupert
murdoch damals vor allem von dem wunsch
getrieben war dem ruf seines vaters
gerecht zu werden
es war eine angespannte beziehung sein
vater war ziemlich distanziert es war
schwer etwas freundliches aus ihm
herauszubekommen
führt er eine starke zuneigung zu seinem
vater und zu dem was er erreicht hat
entschlossen den stolz zu machen
im oktober 1952 als er und oxford
studierte erfuhr murdoch dass sein vater
im alter von 67 jahren an krebs und
herzproblemen gestorben als er nach
hause zurückkehrte sah er seine mutter
von den kollegen seines vaters unter
druck gesetzt wurde ihre zeitungen auf
beteiligungen zu verkaufen ruppert war
entsetzt wie seine mutter an und über
den mangel angriff besser
vom verkauf bedroht war unter anderem
ein boulevard-blatt mit einer auflage
von nur 75.000
nach seinem abschluss in oxford ging
murdoch zurück nach australien und
übernahm die kontrolle
schon bald hatte er seine finger in
allen unternehmensbereichen
war extrem
ich weiß aus eigener erfahrung sagt er
die gleichen redaktionellen fähigkeiten
hatte wie alle andere
1958 machte er seinen ersten vorstoß in
ein anderes medium das fernsehen mit
einem kleinen lokalen sender
aber eines der dinge an die sich die
leute mich erinnern ist dass hubert
schon ende der 50er anfang der 60er
jahre in australien ein fernsehen etwas
besser und das ist eines der dinge die
ihn hierher brachte er hatte
wiederholungsrechte und für rechtes von
amerikanischen studios und netzwerken
gekauft
eine nationale zeitung zu gründen
1964 startete er die australian
man sagte ihnen das werde nicht
funktionieren die entfernung sei zu groß
und es gebe nicht genug nationale
werbung um das blatt aufrecht zu
erhalten man sagte ihnen er werde auch
kein personal finden weil kein guter
journalist für eine zeitung arbeiten
wolle die so eindeutig zum scheitern
verurteilt sei
die zeitung hatte von anfang an eine
liberale haltung und der verantwortliche
mann war immer präsent
rupert lief praktisch jeden abend im
büro auf und ab ging dann spät abends um
22 uhr gegen redaktionsschluss in der
zeitung herum meistens in so einem
leuchtend gelben regenmantel und wurde
gelegentlich von einem der mitarbeiter
die ihm nicht so gut kannten mit einer
reinigungskraft verwechselt
madox direkte kontrolle über seine
zeitungen
ich mische mich schon sehr in die
zeitungen ein aber ich glaube
andererseits was ich meinen redakteuren
auch große freiheiten im alter von 25
jahren heiratete murdoch und bekam eine
tochter prudence die er wurde nach elf
jahren geschieden
1967 heiratete er seine zweite frau erna
dorf mit ihr bekam er in den nächsten
fünf jahren drei kinder
lachen
wichtig ist es seine familie und seine
firma ich glaube das sind diese dinge
die in seinem kopf absolut miteinander
verbunden ähnliches man mit dem alter
wurden seine ansichten konzert
wurde mehr und mehr zum gefangenen der
geschäftswelt in sydney
und wenn er in den yachtclub ging
machten sich die anderen immer über ihn
lustig und fragten nach wie geht es
deinem roten lampen voller zeitung
ruppert
rupert ist glaube ich vor allem an macht
interessiert
man könnte fast sagen er ist
größenwahnsinnig er möchte so viel wie
möglich besitzen soviel wie möglich
beeinflussen die größte und beste sein
den es je gab oder geben wird
ende der 60er jahre war rupert murdoch
auf einem anderen container gelandet und
in einem der wettbewerbsintensivsten
märkten der welt der definition des
alten establishment
londoner fleet street
wo er auf den berüchtigten
medienmagnaten rupert
murdoch fing an gegen seine bekannten
konkurrenten in den
hubers geschäftsstrategie als zeitungs
strategie betrachten es ist ein zeitungs
krieg es gibt immer jemanden der sterben
muss damit man leben kann
mit einem doppelschlag überlistete er
max will und kaufte die beliebten club
süchtige
und die schwächelnde tageszeitung
er belebte sie wieder baute sie in
kürzester zeit zu einem kraftwerk auf
die leser waren vor allem männer die
eine kombination wollten aus sport
sexskandalen politik und oben ohne
mädchen
charlie beckett ist medienanalyst an der
london school of economics
release an ob man sie nun mag oder nicht
und millionen von menschen liebten sie
hat einen riesigen kulturellen einfluss
gehabt sowohl zum guten als auch zum
bösen sie hatte einen stil der die
öffentlichkeit für sehr reale themen
sensibilisiert hat und sie war natürlich
ein fantastischer kommerzieller erfolg
die er erobern wollte amerika
hat sich in australien niveau geführt
braucht nicht in großbritannien aber kam
hier an und dachte sofort muss das ist
mein zuhause
[Musik]
1973 ließ sich murdoch mit seiner
familie in der wohlhabenden ab
er wollte expandieren aber um auf dem us
markt fuß zu fassen musste er sich mit
seiner kleinen regionalzeitung zufrieden
geben die bike auf seine zeitung in san
antonio texas er kaufte sie weil er es
sich leisten kann
als nächstes wollte murdoch eine
nationale präsenz es also gründete er
eine zeitung kommt ist da um gegen den
reißerischen national enquirer
später scheinen
von den bergen in amerika in
supermärkten verkauft das heißt wir
müssen für frauen sei es war nie ein
richtig erfolgreiches experiment
trotzdem verkaufte er später einen
aufgeputschten star für 400 millionen
dollar an die muttergesellschaft des
national enquirer
war es ein verlassen des liberales
boulevardblatt seine fantasie beflügelt
die new york post der 1976 für 30
millionen dollar
wenig später erwarb er gegen den
widerstand der arbeitnehmer das new york
magazine für 75 millionen
inklusive der liberalen wird wo es ist
schwer sich eine publikation
vorzustellen weniger zu rupert murdoch
passt als im village voice
warf einen ansehnlichen gewinn ab jahre
später verkaufte murdoch sie für 55
millionen dollar
murdoch war jetzt auch in klar in new
york im januar 77 schmückte er das
titelblatt des time magazine service
king kong der über der stadt thront nach
den einflussreichsten blättern greift
patience darunter auch die post kommen
dass der ehemalige herausgeber der
zeitung lag im sterben wenn man so will
rupert murdoch investierte in das blatt
sowohl finanziell als auch personell
anderthalb jahre später investierten wir
in neue druckmaschinen um der zeitung
farbe zu geben
seiten hin zu und machten alles was man
tun würde und der zeitung mehr substanz
zu geben
instinkte lebte die zeitung mit aufsehen
erregen dann schlagt sein der inhalt
nach kombiniert und klatsch und tratsch
spucken und spielen
zeitungen verkaufen sich über
schlagzeilen aber langfristig müssen sie
auch substanz haben die leute kaufen sie
nicht wenn sie die einmal angeschaut
haben und nichts finden es ist also
wirklich ein zweistufiger prozess
die post wurde sehr beliebt
finanziell war sie eine katastrophe und
verlor jedes jahr millionen von dollar
ich glaube nicht dass es rupert unter
dem strich nur darum geht zu gewinnen
ihnen gefällt der gedanke dass er
dadurch einen platz am tisch bekommt
dass er seine position nach außen tragen
kann dass er zugang zu politikern
bekommt tischen
[Musik]
ein wichtiger akteur
er beteuerte seinen redakteuren große
freiheiten einzuräumen aber diese
botschaft kam nicht immer bei den
mitarbeitern
die
geschichten hubert war einfach überall
jemand sagte zu ihm ist der mörder da
gibt es einen widerspruch
sie sagten dass sie ihren redakteuren
erlauben die zeitung zu leiten und er
sagte das ist kein widerspruch
sie kenne bloß die redakteure die ich
einstelle
und dann gibt es die leute und
stellt gern leute ein die ihm dankbar
dafür sind dass er/sie eingestellt hat
solche auf deren loyalität erzählen kann
das stellt nicht gerne leute ein die mit
ihm konkurrieren kann die das gefühl
haben könnten dass sie auf der gleichen
ebene stieg er
in die kontrolle die er über seine
nachrichtenorganisationen ausübt besteht
nicht wirklich daran dass er ins telefon
schreit
man hat eher das gefühl dass seine
redakteure wissen was er will und dass
sie das gerne umsetzen
was rupert wolff zeigte sich schon bald
in einer jahrzehntelangen
1981 kaufte er die angesehene times und
die sunday times in london
zurück in den staaten holte er sich den
posten harry und die chicago sun-times
und wurde erneut mit einer revolte vier
topmanager der sun times haben ihren
rücktritt erklärt darunter verleger
james und der kolumnist micro hat sich
beurlauben lassen
ich würde nie für seine zeitung arbeiten
nicht in new york nicht in washington
nicht in san antonio das ist schon
1985 kaufte the twentieth century fox
ein geschäft von zentraler bedeutung
denn es ist ein crossover er ist ein
mann der im verlagswesen tätig ist und
jetzt ein filmstudio kauf
er zeige den ex-ehemann marvin bis 250
millionen für eine 50 prozentige
beteiligung an dem studio
es war schwierig die ersten 50 prozent
von davis zu kriegen aber dann bekam er
die anderen 50 prozent für schlappe 325
dollar
und so übernahme das gesamte filmstudio
twentieth century fox ist eine multi
milliarden schwere anlage für knapp eine
halbe milliarde dollar
[Musik]
er hat mir mal gesagt dass die filme der
nervenkitzel sind man braucht den
nervenkitzel wenn man den rest des
medienimperiums schon hat er braucht sie
weil auf diese weise kreative leute in
das unternehmen kommen
vor allem im riskanten multi millionen
dollar films
der großartigsten dinge an rückhalt ist
dass er in einer krise der coolste und
ruhig
und wenn er dich unterstützt und hatte
ich glaub wird er immer hinter dir
stehen
wenn er an dich glaubst du ehrlich zu
ihm von der angemessenheit seine
entscheidung überzeugt wer der beste
mann den du dir in einem schützengraben
wollte sein unternehmen erweitern indem
er sich in den us fernsehen
aber da gab es ein ernsthaftes problem
es gibt eine vorschrift dass man
staatsbürger der vereinigten staaten
sein muss um einen fernsehsender zu
besitzen und rupert der pragmatiker
beschloss wenn das nötig ist werde ich
eben us bürger
oder rupert murdoch amerikanischer
und ein enger freund
als murdoch seine australische
staatsbürgerschaft aufgab um die
amerikanische aufzunehmen wurde er dafür
kritisiert aber das unternehmen war nun
mal dort und der größte markt ist in den
usa es ist nicht so dass er die
amerikanische staatsbürgerschaft nur
angenommen hat um dort ein medienraum zu
sein er hat sich entschieden sein leben
in amerika zu verbringen
er bezahlte john logie von metro media
bis zu 2 milliarden dollar im
fernsehsender m6 großen
nbc cbs und es gab keinen platz für ein
weiteres netzwerk
daher und starb ein viertes netzwerk
er sah dass es einen großen spielraum
für netzwerk gab das jüngere zuschauer
anzieht und eine größere vielfalt an
zuschauer aber aus dem hochkarätigen db
oder einen schweren schlag
das ist die peep taste wir gehen live
drauf und das heißt kein piep
scheiterte kläglich gegen den
unerschütterlichen johnny castle für das
junge team eine bittere lektion
der ehemalige präsident
seit den 50er jahren hatte niemand mehr
eine senderkette gegründet wir mussten
erst mal herausfinden wie ein network
sein muss dass sich von nbc abc und cbs
unterscheidet sowie nachhinein scheint
es offensichtlich so ja wenn du endest
wenn cbs sendet dann wirst du keinen
erfolg haben
machte sich daran tochter länder zu
können
es gab kreative freiheit und sicherlich
mehr als die beiden anderen networks
bekommen würden aber wir haben auch
größere aufträge wir setzten direkt auf
serien weil wir das mussten wir hatten
ja nur ein jahr zeit um das ganze
aufzubauen und zum laufen zu bringen und
spaß mit einer reihe von sendungen die
sich gegen die konkurrenz durchsetzen
begann der vierte sender sich in den
einschaltquoten zu machen
[Musik]
wall street jankowski children and
family show ich meine der arbeitstitel
von mary children war nicht die kospi
und living colour all diese dinge wurden
viel mehr es muss einfach anders sein
als die sachen auf den anderen kanälen
und nichts war so anders wie die sendung
die alles verändern sollte der größte
wendepunkt waren die simpsons
rupert hat es über alles geliebt den
sende transfair stellen er war wie ein
kind in einem süßwarenladen und ich habe
immer witze darüber gemacht war dass er
aufsprang und an pfingsten an die tafel
zu machen sich zu fragen wie es das und
wie ihr mann na ja nicht richtig gut
werden hängt er etwas anderes hin aber
irgendwann sprang auf und nahm die
simpsons und stellte sie am
donnerstagabend gegen die cosby show er
wollte diese winzige kleine sendungen
der wir gerade erst angefangen hatten
gegen die nummer eins im fernsehen
antreten lassen und zuerst dachten wir
ehrlich gesagt alle ihr seid verrückt
wie gesagt das können wir nicht machen
werden vernichtet und er sagt wir immer
wieder raus vertraut mir das wird
funktionieren was liegen war zu
einhundert prozent pa cd während murdoch
ins amerikanische fernsehen expandierte
erlöste er in london eine revolte der
mächtigen britischen presse
gewerkschaften
das sollte die hauptstadt der zeitungen
sein und all die arbeit ist durch die
aktivitäten der londoner gewerkschaften
verloren gegangen um die
zeitungsproduktion zu automatisieren
verlegte murdoch sie von der fleet
street in ein wert im londoner
das neue effiziente wer braucht er
weniger arbeitskräfte über 5000
murdoch plante sie alle zu entlassen
als ehemalige generalsekretär in der
britischen drucker gewerkschaft
verhandelte baroness brenders die
murdoch in arbeitsplätze zu retten
besonders teuer war verständlicherweise
der meinung dass er nicht mit den alten
arbeitspraktiken aus der fleet street in
ein neues werk umzieht dass diese alten
ideen nicht
was er wollte das war ein extrem
radikales abkommen im unternehmen hat
aber das wird ja nicht bekommen wir
waren immer noch bereit zu verhandeln
und er hörte zu und sagte am ende die
musik hat sich geändert aber der tanz
bleibt
was brender die nicht wusste war dass
murdoch bereits eine geheime abmachung
mit der elektriker gewerkschaft
getroffen hatte und schnell mit einer
probe druckauflage voranzukommen
und deine kurs von sweeney als wir das
erfuhren als wir wussten was sie einen
probelauf durch hilfe versagt sich als
generalsekretären erst mal zu unseren
leuten statt auf streik heute
[Musik]
murdoch bekam unterstützung von einer
alten freundin margaret thatcher die das
management den gewerkschaften vorzug er
hatte sie unterstützt als sie als
premierministerin kandidierte
und das zahlte sich aus
/ us regierung erliess gesetze und in
diesem internationalen nachrichten
streit im walking streit wie bekannt
wurde wurde die sogenannte
gewerkschaftliche gesetzgebung zu einem
schlüsselfaktor dafür dass rupert
murdoch
tausende kamen um die proteste zu
unterstützen aber die demonstrationen
nahmen eine gewalttätige window
shopping wurde die festung genannt
wirklich alle war es gab
sicherheitsvorkehrungen es wurde eine
murdoch miliz ausgerufen er wurde
dämonisiert
ziemlich schreckliche sachen ich habe
gesehen wie ein hat meiner mitglieder
von der polizei verprügelt wurden wurde
gewalt angewendet kein zweifel wir
versuchten das rekonstruieren manchmal
konnten wir sonntag wir können mit hilfe
von zetsches zerschlug murdoch die
gewerkschaften und sein werk in woking
war balls auf dem formen
aber er hat am ende
einige der den arbeit in den räten brach
es war ein bahnbrechender moment nicht
nur in der geschichte der arbeiterschaft
sondern in der geschichte
dass es nicht vernünftig dass es nicht
logisch der fortschritt verlangt dass
die regeln ändern
und murdochs einkaufstouren weißer
interniert
1988 kaufte er für drei milliarden
dollar das einen berg magazin imperium
murdoch schockierender preis war der
größte der je für ein verlagshaus
gezahlt wurde doch dann wurde er durch
vorschriften gestoppt
der besitz einer zeitung und eines
fernsehsenders in einem einzigen markt
waren untersagt murdoch war gezwungen
seine beliebte in new york post zu
verkaufen
jahre später konnte er sie für 25
millionen dollar zurückkaufen nachdem er
eine sondergenehmigung erhalten
die post am leben erhalten weil er sie
am leben erhalten wollten niemand sonst
in der news corporation heute dass die
leute sehen bei der post arbeit es macht
wirtschaftlich einfach keinen sinn
unvermindert griff murdoch wortwörtlich
nach dem himmel ein
großes wagnis war das
satellitenfernsehen
das fernsehen zu starten gegen eine hoch
finanzierte etablierte plattform namens
kritisch satellite broadcasting
einem der größten player aller zeiten
schrieb das unternehmen fast in den
bankrott
das lautet die explosion des fernsehens
in ganz europa und dem rest der welt ein
unternehmen
bietet seiner investition
wie sky blutete aus und murdoch hatte
sich durch seine kauf orgien bei den
gläubigern gefährlich verschuldet
glücklicherweise beschlossen 145 banken
mehr zeit zu geben eine bank in
pittsburgh weigerte sich jedoch und
drohte einen kredit von 10 millionen
dollar hin zu fördern zu der partie mit
den banken geschlossen hatte bestand
darin dass wenn eine bank den kredit
einforderte alle anderen kredite auch
fällig wurden mit einem anruf bei der
bank in pittsburgh rettete murdoch sein
unternehmen vor dem zusammenbruch
das waren diese unglaubliche leistung
mit er es geschafft hat das unternehmen
zu retten er musste zahlen davon
verkaufen magazine er musste sich zur
besseren geschäftspraktiken verpflichten
die banken sagten ihm er müsse sich
benehmen
er musste fast acht milliarden dollar
schulden umstrukturieren das war eine
nahtoderfahrung für sein unternehmen
vorher musste immer alles ganz schnell
gehen
für strukturierte
noch 1993 war er zurück am pokertisch er
gab eine milliarde dollar für den
chinesischen fernsehsender star tv aus
porta bibb ist ein amerikanischer medien
analyst und verleger
nach jena durch star das
satellitenfernsehen dass er in hongkong
aufbaute
dadurch hatte er in den frühen 90ern
breiten zugang zu einem medienmarkt die
axel dem rest der westlichen länder im
grunde verschlossen war
am ersten september 93 verspielte er
diesen zugang murdoch hielt eine rede in
london wie die chinesische regierung
die fortschritte in der
telekommunikations technologie haben
sich als eindeutige bedrohung für
totalitäre regimes erwiesen überall
chinesen schlugen zurück indem sie den
privaten besitz von satellitenschüsseln
verboten und damit auch murdochs zugang
zu millionen haushalten partie war unter
beschuss
doch musste die chinesische regierung
besänftigen zu ihrem namen die
ungeliebte bbc vom sender und
vernichtete einen china kritisches buch
des ex gouverneurs von
die chinesische führung war besänftigt
und
murdoch vor vor ort chinesische beamte
zu umwerben diese die präsenz von news
corp in china aus in china scheine in
china ist die neue welt das ist die
zukunft und er hat das früher erkannt
als die meisten anderen reden aber fast
nichts funktioniert in china sein
konkurrent war die chinesische regierung
hat mit der chinesischen regierung kann
er nicht konkurrieren
ist kein großer sportfan
doch in der firma 93 nahm er eine
amerikanische obsession und
er traf mit einem atemberaubenden
angebot von über anderthalb milliarden
dollar schnappte er sich die rechte an
den national von cbs
ich glaube nicht dass wir jemals einen
deal gemacht haben bei dem wir am
nächsten morgen nicht mit
gewissensbissen aufgewacht sind aber das
ist eigentlich gut denn es sportlich am
noch härter zu arbeiten
hätte das ein großer fan sein können
die football liga war sehr mutig fans
fox hatte nichts keine sportabteilung
wir sollten froh sein ich habe dort
gesehen wir sind vor sport singular sie
sind ein riesiges risiko eingegangen was
würden sie tun wenn sie es vermessen
wenn unsere show vor dem spiel ein
scherbenhaufen gewesen wären wenn das
set auseinander gefallen wäre und dann
wenn die übertragung beginnt wir die
touchdowns verpassen wir haben es nicht
drauf die ansager liegen falsch
und was wäre wenn er nicht alle
amerikaner erreichen würde die football
lieben murdoch zuckt nicht mit der
wimper er investierte weitere 500
millionen dollar in new world
communications und dem versierten
investoren gehört köln wechselte
daraufhin mit zwölf seiner wichtigsten
fernsehsender zuvor
es war die grösste sender umstellung in
der geschichte des us fernsehens
und ein glücksfall für die lokalen wende
die nfl auf fortschritt jährlich über
900 millionen dollar und hat bis zu 20
millionen zuschauer die woche news
mörder war auf dem aufsteigenden ast
wollte halt zu seinen wurzeln
zurückkehren er fand sich in der
fernsehbranche wieder die ihr gar nicht
mag ich glaube er hat nie eine volle
stunde fernsehen zur hauptsendezeit
geguckt aber er mag das
nachrichtengeschäft mitte der 90er jahre
wollte murdoch den einzigen 24-stündigen
nachrichtensenders cnn kaufen aber
dessen eigentümer ted turner verachte
ich mag's politik hat seine ansprüche
und das beruhte auf gegenseitigkeit
sondern verkaufte cnn schließlich
widerwillig sozialem aber nicht an
murdoch
1996 ging der sender im rahmen einer 75
milliarden dollar fusion mit turner
broadcasting am 2
murdoch musste sich etwas anderes
einfallen lassen er ließ sich nicht
beirren und gründete seinen eigenen
sender um sich mit cms
etablierte sich schnell als bühne für
konservative ansichten
ein teil des geschäftsplans ist man
sollte nicht mit ihnen konkurrieren oder
ihren sollte sich um das grundherr
versorgte publikum bemüht und man sollte
das so machen bestens billiger ist als
reporter in die ganze welt zu schützen
also hatten wir nur kommentatoren pinien
und das funktionierte und zwar
unglaublich gut
einen ex berater konservativer politiker
richard nixon bis george bush robert ist
von natur aus konservativ vielleicht
nicht so konservativ wie roger e mails
aber ihm gefiel die tatsache dass roger
einen plan für fox news hatte fox hatte
zu beginn viel geld verloren rupert
musste sogar kabelanbieter bezahlen
damit sie zu übernehmen
kontrovers und machte die liberalen
waren
und auch die ausländischen verbündeten
die aktiv gegen unser militär arbeiten
sobald der krieg begonnen hat betrachte
ich als staatsfeinde
mit dem slogan fair und ausgewogen
besteht der ehemalige präsident und ceo
von news corp peter turner darauf dass
fox news einen unterschied nachrichten
es gibt nachrichten bei fox news die
tatsächlich sehr neutral und moderat und
fair präsentiert werden und dann gibt es
tag und meinungs- shows von denen
niemand behauptet dass wir nachrichten
sachlich
oder sean hannity sind eindeutig leute
auf der rechten seite des spektrums sie
wurden aber auch immer als solche
präsentieren
und wurde zum profitabelsten kabel
nachrichtensender in
murdochs privatleben braut sich etwas
zusammen
1999 ließ er sich nach 32 jahren von
seiner frau anna scheiben mit einer der
größten abfindungen der geschichte und
der 68 jährige murdoch heiratete direkt
die 30-jährige eine
absolventin der yale school of
management und ehemalige vize
präsidentin von star tv murdochs
persönliches leben schien wieder in
ordnung zu sein aber weniger als ein
jahr später wurde bei ihm frühestens
mit 70 jahren
mit 72
2003 im alter von 72 jahren zählte
murdoch auf eine weitere fernseh trug
er wollte schon seit einem jahrzehnt
einen satelliten geschäft in den usa er
verhandelte fast zwei jahre lang mit dem
vorstand von general motors irgendwann
verkauften sie widerwillig anmutet
directv
angebot sicherte ihm einen anteil von 34
prozent eine bizarre kette von
ereignissen zwang ihm nur ein jahr
später dazu ihn wieder aufzugeben
während er 2004 die wiederwahl von
george bush feierte lieber sah murdoch
dass ein riesiges aktienpaket seines
unternehmens news corp in australien auf
den markt kam
als sie in den amerikanischen markt
übertragen
rupert wachte eines morgens auf und
sagte heiliger bimbam dieser typ besitzt
16 seines unternehmens er weiß ja dass
john malone ein cleverer geschäftsmann
ist leons anteil an news corp warum
derzeit größte nach murdoch um diesen
einzel an seinem unternehmen zurück zu
bekommen musste was etwas von
erheblichem wert abgeben um john malone
los zu werden musste er diesen anteil
schließlich gegen directv eintauschen
ich glaube er wollte vielleicht an
directv festhalten das war inzwischen
ein wirklich starker programmanbieter
und robert hatte keinen nationalen
vertrieb das hätte ihm wahrscheinlich
gefallen
nachdem er seine aktien zurück gewonnen
hatte kaufte murdoch 2005 die
internetplattform myspace
er zahlte einen hohen preis um einen
konkurrenten auszustechen
diesmal sammler redstone von
seiner sicht eine tragisch komische oder
myspace das war wissen sie wer kauft
erst für
ich glaube etwas mehr als 500 millionen
dollar ich glaube einem zeitpunkt da
wurde sogar auf 25 milliarden geschätzt
also kehrte murdoch auf bekanntes
terrain zurück und richtete seinen blick
auf eine der angesehensten zeitung
und war früher reporterin bei der
zeitung als ich mit leuten über murdoch
und seine vorliebe für das wall street
journal sprach sagten sogar seine kinder
sie könnten sich an keine zeit erinnern
in der er nicht über die zeitung
gesprochen hätte das wall street journal
und die muttergesellschaft dow jones
waren im besitz der beiden kraft einer
prominenten boss der familie
hat schon dreimal versucht das wall
street journal zu kaufen
auf eine unglaublich hoch
zum ersten mal von dem zerwürfnis in der
bank oft familie erfuhr der die zeitung
seit über 100 jahren gehörte er schon
die keine
dort nutzte den moment und machte ein
angebot die aktie wurde für 36 dollar
gehandelt murdoch droht stolze 60 dollar
jay ist ehemaliger vize präsident und
direktor von bak
ich erinnere mich genau ich war
geschockt enttäuscht darüber dass man
journalismus mit dem unternehmen enden
würde für dass ich hart gearbeitet hatte
um gute ausgaben für das wall street
journal zu machen es wohnt dass sie von
einem mann übernommen wird den ich nicht
wirklich bewunderte
das schwindelerregende angebots spaltet
da waren jetzt kinder die drohten ihre
eltern zu verklagen wenn sie an murdoch
verkaufen
ich dachte es würde dem ansehen des wall
street journal schaden wenn er die
journalistischen prinzipien anwendet die
er ja fast sein ganzes leben lang
verfolgt hat nämlich seine feinde
anzugreifen seine freunde zu
unterstützen und politiker zu
unterstützen die ihm zu vorteilen
verhelfen könnten
doch versprach die qualität der zeitung
zu erhalten und die mitarbeiter zu
übernehmen
unabhängig bleiben ich sag nichts mehr
ich habe gesehen dass er den eigentümern
immer mehr versprechen gemacht und sie
dann gebrochen hat er versprach würde
die standard der times of london beide
halten und an dem redakteur harry evans
festhalten und innerhalb eines jahres
hatte evans gefeuert
also gaben die bank hofft nach am ersten
august 2007 schloss dow jones --eine
vereinbart
[Musik]
ich habe seine aufregung mitbekommen
dass jalloh gekauft hat
enorme gefühl der befriedigung und er
dachte über sein leben nach er wird
wirklich zeit mit diesem journal
verbringen
nicht jeder war so begeistert
wir sind heute hier um allen zu sagen
dass sie wissen sollten dass rupert
murdoch das wall street journal gekauft
hat wenig überraschend brach murdoch
bald seine versprechen und holte seine
einige leute rein
es gelang ihnen sozusagen durch die
hintertür die kultur mit einem schlag
kaputt zu machen und das ego der leute
die beim wall street journal arbeiteten
anzukratzen
doch murdoch überraschte viele seiner
kritiker
und wurde zur nummer eins der
tageszeitungen in amerika
rupert murdoch der löwe im winter wurde
2011 80 jahre alt nach 60 jahren wieder
spitze eines medienimperiums stellte
sich die frage wer ihm nachfolgen würde
ich glaube er freut sich auf den tag an
dem seine drei kinder die sich für das
unternehmen interessieren gemeinsam für
ihn arbeiten er freut sich auf den tag
an dem es rupert mal vier gibt magath
kaufte die fernseh produktionsfirma
shine in seiner tochter elisabeth
700 millionen dollar in tucson
lächeln kehrte nach einer erfolglosen
karriere bei news corp nach australien
zurück und den sendern network ten zu
leiten oder jüngste sohn james wurde
stellvertretende geschäftsführer news
corp in new york wir sind sehr
wettbewerbsorientiert und zwar in dem
maß dass wir dort wo wir marktanteile
gewinnen müssen diese auch erobern
werden dieser wettbewerbsgeist sickerten
die unternehmenskultur ein mit
verheerenden folgen
medien
die sprachnachrichten eines jungen
mordopfers und ihrer familie abhängt und
die polizei für informationen bezahlt
lewis war anfangs wurde das als ein
weiterer kleiner schmutziger skandal
einiger journalisten angesehen die mit
privatdetektiven zu weit gegangen waren
aber was wir für einen relativ
begrenzten skandal hielten entpuppte
sich als ein allgegenwärtiger
systematischer missbrauch
journalistischer macht
auch die handys von prominenten und
politikern wurden gehackt so fragt
es stellte sich heraus dass dieses
telefon hacking weit verbreitet war das
ist praktisch mit jedem gemacht wurde
wer die möglichkeit bot nachrichten oder
klatscht
um den skandal einzudämmen wurde die 168
jahre alte news of the world im juli
2011 geschlossen
murdoch entschuldigte sich vor einem
britischen parlamentsausschuss
ich möchte nur einzahlen dies ist der
demütigste tag meines lebens seine
mitarbeiter hätten ihnen über das
hacking in die irre geführt
leute denen ich vertraut habe ich sage
nicht mehr und ich weiß nicht wie oft
sie mich im stich gelassen haben aber
sie haben sich schändlich verhalten und
das unternehmen und mich verraten
mitten in der anhörung versuchte ein
demonstrant murdoch mit einer torte
anzugreifen seine frau wendy beschützt
der skandal war schädlich und kost
spielen james der erbe trat als
vorsitzender von gsk wie zurück und news
corp zahlte über 380 millionen dollar an
rechtskosten und vergleichszahlungen
zwei jahre nachdem wendi murdoch ihrem
mann verteidigt hatte im bereich der
rupert murdoch die scheidung ein
er rief von sports network ins leben um
mit ihr spm zu konkurrieren rund um die
aktionäre zu besänftigen spaltete
murdoch im juni 2013 seien sechs
jahrzehnte altes verlagsgeschäft vom
rest des medienimperiums
das neue unternehmen und heute offiziell
den handel auf es ist bereits der größte
zeitungsverlag der vereinigten staaten
mit einem marktwert von 8,8 milliarden
dollar
rupert murdoch hat ein riesiges und
vielfältiges imperium aufgebaut eine
konkurrenzlose und unaufhaltsame
zentrale der macht ist
dies ist ein mann der sowohl in
wirtschaftlicher als auch in politischer
und kultureller hinsicht außerordentlich
mächtig ist
[Musik]
das charakteristische an ihm was ihn zu
einem presse baron macht ist dieses
ständige streben nach mehr und mehr
macht fest und das ist es auch woran wir
uns erinnern werden
im guten wie im schlechten
[Musik]